STEPHANIE WONG: This
week, we're talking
about KubeCon, Cloud Run,
and querying ride share data.
Welcome to "This Week in
Cloud," where we serve
you the lowest latency news.
Even if you didn't get a chance
to attend KubeCon this year,
you can still catch all
the biggest announcements
in one place with this
KubeCon wrap-up post.
Check out cool news like
monitoring Kubernetes
with Stackdriver
and see examples
of customers transforming their
industries with Kubernetes
all in one place.
Read more and see how GKE
puts the "ease" in Kubernetes.
We announced Cloud Run at Next.
But that doesn't mean
we're done just yet.
Check out all the
latest on the GCP Blog
to learn about some new
improvements to Cloud Run,
like Cloud SQL support
and metrics at a glance.
You can also check out the
talk from Next for a deep dive
of how it works.
So take a look and start getting
the most out of Cloud Run.
As if BigQuery couldn't
already do enough,
now you can get
insights even faster
thanks to BigQuery BI Engine.
In a new post, developer
advocate Felipe Hoffa
built a BI dashboard
and explains
how to predict travel time based
on a location and time of day
with a public data
set from Uber.
Try out Felipe's
dashboard for yourself
or get inspired to
see how BigQuery
can help you with your data.
Of course, there's more than
BigQuery and Kubernetes in GCP.
If you're still
exploring, then we've
got a playlist that
you're sure to enjoy--
Getting Started with
Google Cloud Platform.
This is a great set of
resources to learn some new tips
and get the basics on a
wide variety of topics,
from setting up
roles to spinning off
compute and storage offerings.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.